>> Greg: IT WAS ELON MUSK
VERSUS A DRIED UP OLD HUSK.
HE HAS, THE BILLIONAIRE TAKES
TIME OFF FROM SPACE TO GET AN
BERNIE SANDERS FACE.
IT WAS A CEO WHO SENDS ROCKETS
THROUGH THE YEAR VERSUS A
SENATOR WHO IS OLDER THAN DIRT.
TESLA CEO TOOK TO TWITTER OVER
THE WEEKEND RESPONDING TO THE
DEMAND THAT RICH PEOPLE PAY MORE
IN TAXES AND BY RICH, MEANS
PEOPLE THAT OWN MORE THAN THREE
HOUSES.
GENTLE RUMBLE OF LAUGHTER.
BERNIE TWEETED "WE MUST DEMAND
THE EXTREMELY WEALTHY PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF PERIOD."
ONLY TOOK HIM THREE HOURS TO
WRITE THAT TWEET WITH THOSE
MITTENS ON.
THE WORLD'S RICHEST MAN
RESPONDED "I KEEP FORGETTING
THAT YOU'RE STILL ALIVE.
IT HE GETS A BIGGER LAUGH THAN I
DO.
WANT TO SELL MORE STOCK, JUST
SAY THE WORD.
HE ROUGHLY SOLD $7 BILLION WORTH
OF TESLA STOCK AFTER CONDUCTING
A TWITTER POLL ASKING HIS
FOLLOWERS IF YOU SHOULD WHICH IS
EXACTLY HOW YOU SHOULD MAKE
INVESTMENT DECISIONS, ONLY IF
YOU'RE A BILLIONAIRE BUT IT GOT
US WONDERING WHAT DOES
BERNIE SANDERS THINK ABOUT THIS?
>> THIS IS NOT ANYTHING RADICAL
BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE LAWS.
>> YOU END UP WAKING UP AND SHE
STILL SAYS NO.
YOU MISSED NO HOMEWORK, BUT YOUR
TEACHER REACHES CLASS LIKE
YOU'RE SOME KIND OF JERK.
>> CHARGING EXTORTION LEVEL.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO FIGHT FOR YOUR
RIGHT TO PARTY.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE HAD THOSE
BUFFALO WINGS LAST NIGHT.
>> SHOULD NOT BE USING PEOPLE'S
MISFORTUNE.
IT >> NOW I'M FEELING THE BURN.
I'VE GOT TO GET OUT OF HERE.
>> Greg: IT'S KIND OF SAD THAT
OF THE TWO MEN THAT ARE FEUDING,
ONE OF THEM ALMOST BECAME
PRESIDENT AND IT'S NOT THE
BILLIONAIRE.
>> NO COMMENTS THE
MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
WE NEED TO TAX THE RICH.
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH --
HE IS THE UNICORN ANYWAY BECAUSE
HE'S A RICH SOCIALIST WHICH
MEANS HE'S FIGHTING HIMSELF, BUT
WHATEVER IN GOING AFTER
ELON MUSK BECAUSE HE'S CONVINCED
THAT'S WHAT THE PEOPLE WANT TO
HEAR BECAUSE EVEN IF YOU TAX
HIM, AND IS NOT GOING TO MAKE
CHRISTMAS ANY BETTER, NOT GOING
TO FIX SCHOOLS OR WHAT'S GOING
ON IN OUR STREETS LET'S GO AFTER
HIM AND THEN HE COMES BACK
WITH -- IN HIS DEFENSE IF HE HAD
JUST 1 BILLION, MAYBE HE
WOULDN'T BE SO COCKY BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE 265 BILLION, WHAT IS
65 BILLION AMONG FRIENDS, YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> YOU SAID WE SHOULD TAX THE
RICH AND HE SAID THAT'S ME!
I AM RICH!
THE RICHEST MAN IN THE WORLD AND
STILL FEELS HE CAN GO ON TWITTER
AND CALL SOME VERMONT'S WITH
SENATOR MIKE YOUR OLD!
>> Greg: I LOVE THAT.
>> I LOVE THE FACT THAT IT'S
OCCASIONALLY.
ONE OF THE FEW VERY FAMOUS
PEOPLE WHO CLEARLY DOES HAVE
CONTROL OF HIS OWN TWITTER
ACCOUNT AND SEND THESE THINGS
OUT SOMETIMES, NO ONE ELSE WOULD
DO THAT BUT HE HAS.
>> Greg: NO ONE IS GOING TO
CANCEL HIM.
ALTHOUGH I STILL DON'T RESPECT
HIM AFTER WHAT HE DID TO GRIMES.
B MIKE YOU DID CALL IT THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE A KID.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
MEETINGS THEY NEVER SHOW UP FOR.
>> Greg: THE ONE THING THAT
DRIVES ME A LITTLE BIT CRAZY IS
WE HAVE GIVEN UP ANY KIND OF
OPPORTUNITY TO COUNTER SOMEBODY
WHO TALKS ABOUT FAIR SHARE.
SOMEBODY SAYS YOU NEED TO PAY
YOUR FAIR SHARE, THEY CAN SAY
THAT NO MATTER WHAT THE
PERCENTAGE YOU PAY SO 1% OF THE
AMERICAN POPULATION IS PAYING
40% OF THE TAXES, THAT'S STILL
NOT ENOUGH BECAUSE IS NEVER
ENOUGH.
>> BERNIE SANDERS OWNS THREE
MORE HOMES THAN ELON MUSK.
THIS IS A WEIRD THING THE LEFT
DOES.
THEY SAY THEY WANT TO ACHIEVE A
GOAL SO A GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH
BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTS WHICH
MEANS WE NEED A LOT OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
ELON MUSK HAPPENS TO KNOW HOW TO
PRODUCE ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
YET THEY ARE CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO DESTROY HIM SO AT THE SAME
TIME DEMANDING THE PRIVATE
SECTOR GET ON BOARD WITH THIS
BIG GOVERNMENT PROGRAM TRYING TO
MAKE SURE HE HAS LESS MONEY TO
BUILD THE ELECTRIC CARTS THAT HE
NEEDS SO THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE, BUT I DO LOVE THAT HE IS
LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT, FORGOT THAT
YOU EXIST AND THREATENS TO SELL
MORE STOCK TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
BERNIE SANDERS TO DO THAT.
>> WHY IS IT THAT YOU SEE EVERY
TIME SHE TALKS SPEAKS LIKE IT'S
TO A CHILD IT'S NEVER HEARD
ENGLISH.
NOW, LET ME TELL YOU.
>> Greg: THAT'S COMING FROM
YOU SO WHENEVER YOU TALK IT'S
LIKE BATHING IN WARM MILK.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU PUT ME
ON WITH THE GUY WITH A NICE
ACCENT, BUT IT'S REALLY RUDE.
>> Greg: THAT'S THE BEST,
DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE THAT.
>> TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, SHE
SPEAKING TO HERSELF.
>> THAT'S HOW THE VIDEO TOLD HER
TO SPEAK.
YOU WATCH AOC WHEN SHE'S IN
PUBLIC, SHE LEARNED THAT IF YOU
JUMP AND POINT WHILE YOU TALK.
BECAUSE THEY WENT TO THE SAME
CLASS.
THEY WON'T LISTEN TO THE DUMB
[BLEEP]